foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
tonight I'll Piers Morgan uncensored as
Harry and Megan broke a deal to crash
the king's coronation Prince Andrews in
hot water over this bizarre bathtub bid
to clear his name is it time for King
Charles to banish the Rogue Royals
protesting the US a shocking body cam
footage shows 29 year old Tire Nichols
beaten and killed by five police
officers all five of them were black
so why is this horror being blamed on
racist white supremacy we'll debate that
thus as SMP did a Nicholas sturgeon
faces the slew of Scandal caused by her
own inability to Define females I'm
joined live by Matt Walsh The Man Behind
the Smash Hit film what is a woman maybe
he can help Miss sturgeon
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored well good evening London
welcome to Piers Morgan on sense that
Prince Andrew's ever been The Brightest
Bulb in the Royal box but his decision
to launch a legal bid to reopen his sex
abuse case maybe his dimmest move yet
the Duke spent Millions much of it
provided by the late Queen and therefore
ultimately by you and I to settle with
Virginia du Frey out of court we were
told that was to avoid the likely
embarrassment of Andrew on the witness
stand after the embarrassment of Andrew
on Newsnight
it was a shooting weekend a shooting
weekend just a straightforward
straightforward shooting weekend I was
at home I was with the children I'd
taken Beatrice to
a Pizza Express in working she described
dancing with you and you profusely
sweating and that she went on to have
bars possibly there's a slight problem
with with with with the sweating
um because I I
have a
peculiar medical condition which is that
I don't sweat
will you be forgiven for thinking of
Duke's absurdist Alibis a shockingly dry
armpits and a shockingly memorable Pizza
as bizarre as it could get but Along
Came this at the weekend a quite
ludicrous staged photograph released by
friends of jails sex trafficker gilet
Maxwell friend of Andrew which
supposedly clear the Duke by proving
there simply wasn't space in her bathtub
for the alleged to toe licking that took
place there
well first this is a Tory a mad cap
stunt which is completely beneath anyone
in the royal family but secondly it
actually proves the exact opposite of
what Andrew's Defenders claim Virginia
dufre then age 17 underage in America at
the time in the states where she says
Andrew committed the offenses says that
he licked her toes in the bath before
later having sex with her well not only
does the photograph actually prove there
was ample room the toe related to
frolicking it also shows the unserver as
duke made us sit at the tap end of the
tub
and with historically bad timing
apparent prove has now emerged the
infamous photograph of Andrew averaging
du Frey in gilaine Maxwell's house is in
fact real here's what Maxwell told TV
from behind bars last week
with the fake I don't believe that I
don't believe it's a real for a second a
second I'm sure it's not there's never
been an original and further there's no
photograph right and have they never
seen a photocopy of it
and here's what Andrew himself said
I think it's from the investigations
that we've done you can't prove whether
or not that photograph is uh faked or
not because it is a photograph of a
photograph of a photograph
so it's very difficult to be able to to
um to prove it but
I I don't remember that photograph ever
being taken
well it seems now that the photograph is
real this weekend we learned from the
mail on Sunday that it has a date and a
time stamp locating it to a convenience
store just two minutes from Virginia
Frey's home in Florida developed three
days after the meeting happened would
you Freya is not planning to write a
book about her experience it's due out
quite soon because there was a one-year
ban as part of the settlement with
Andrew before she could talk publicly
the Duke is now threatening her it's
reported with an 81 million pound
lawsuit if she repeats her claims but
these are the same claims he just paid
him millions of dollars to avoid
disputing in court
in the court of public opinion Andrew
looks deeply embarrassing
but the very serious consequence of all
this is inevitable briefing and smearing
by both sides dragging the reputation of
the monarchy into the gutter with Andrew
again meanwhile Harry and Megan who've
done more than enough of that already
they're also haggling to now be at the
king's coronation and celebrate with the
best of British and the king is
reportedly asking the Archbishop of
Canterbury to broker of peace deal for
his son to appear at the coronation now
it's understandable that he wants to
reconcile with his brother and Son
before the biggest day of his life the
state occasions like the coronation
belonged not just to the royal family
but to the people of Britain and the
Commonwealth if Harry and Megan refused
to apologize we think we know they won't
and if Andrew continues to embarrass
himself and Britain by continuing to
dispute something he's already settled
then my view is that King Charles should
ban all three of them from his
coronation well joining me is the Royal
editor of Vanity Fair Katie Nichol
journalist and friend of the queen
consort Perpetual Wyatt and lawyer Alan
dershowitz he was also sued by Virginia
Jew Freight which he dropped her case
and now acknowledges it was likely
mistaken identity well welcome to all of
you Alan good to talk to you not spoken
to you for a long time I appreciate you
coming on the program tonight first of
all let me just ask you about this idea
that Andrew may now go back in and try
and recontest this case with Virginia
dufraid because of what happened in your
case with her where you always denied
all the allegations that she threw at
you and she ultimately admitted that it
may be mistaken identity she's a bigot
you're wrong and mixed up with somebody
else
is that enough for prince Andrew to go
back in and try and relitigate all this
well I think it's part of a larger
package uh I'm not going to comment
specifically on the case but I can tell
you that you can undo deals if there was
a fraud on the court if the plaintiff
allege things that weren't true and one
specific thing of course is that she
swore under oath and her everybody swore
under oath in the case that she lived in
Colorado and if it could be proved that
she didn't live in Colorado again I'm
talking hypothetically that could uh
possibly reopen the case also there was
a deal made in which she agreed not to
sue any Associates of Epstein including
quote royalty so these are at least
hypothetically the kinds of arguments
that could be made legally I think my
own case
may add kind of an atmospheric to it she
admitted after all these years and I
haven't on the cover of my book I now
recognize that I may have made a mistake
in identifying Alan dershowitz you know
years ago I wrote a book laying out all
the evidence but now she's made this
acknowledgment that creates a kind of
atmospheric but
but less of a legal claim the legal
claims tend to be more jurisdictional
procedural fraud that kind of thing
okay I mean I I know that you've in the
past also shed doubt over the veracity
of this Infamous photograph of Andrew
with his arm around a young virginity
you free but the men on Sunday here in
the UK at the weekend at a pretty
damning dossier in which they really
reveal that this picture is almost
certainly genuine it had watermarks on
it they had examined them uh they it was
processed within three days of this
alleged encounter which she claimed with
prince Andrew and so on and so on in
light of that dossier they published
have you changed your mind about this
picture
oh I never said it was false I just said
that the original was never disclosed so
that it creates a difficulty
um I actually wrote an email to Glenn
Maxwell uh essentially asking her what
she thought because she's in the picture
I have no basis more than you do or any
of your viewers do for knowing whether
the picture was authentic or not but I
would hope that sometime they might
produce the original picture which could
finally resolve this issue
the fact that she got it wrong about you
Virginia Frey that doesn't of course
mean that she got it wrong about Andrew
does it
no of course not uh but it does you know
affect possibly the the the certainty of
any
um uh allegation because she certainly
made the allegations against me with uh
with great certainty and Assurance uh uh
saying that it happened what seven times
in different places uh so it it might be
relevant to the case but certainly not
just positive
I mean she now has a book coming out
which is going to reveal a number of New
Revelations we're told Andrew we're
reading every day is planning
potentially to launch a new legal
challenge tool these allegations and yet
the center of this you have a guy who is
the Queen's son
who said repeatedly I will clear my name
in court I want to have my day I want to
clear my name and then and then right at
the last minute he settled for millions
of dollars to a woman that he claimed he
never met
that seems to me to be the central
problem with his position because if he
genuinely had never met her and he
genuinely wanted to clear his name in
court well why didn't he
well the question is what pressure is
the royal family his mother particularly
experiencing her Jubilee might have
placed uh on him cases get settled for
all kinds of reasons and of course there
was no admission of guilt in the
settlement but you know the public has
the right to take into account all of
the factors I wish the media would do a
better job in investigating accusations
in general women must be taken seriously
and when a woman makes an accusation it
must be taken seriously that means it
must be investigated thoroughly and I do
not think today in the metoo movement
many of these allegations are thoroughly
investigated by the media they have
usually a narrative and they go with the
narrative they're terrified about
investigating alleged victims I guess
they'll be accused of victim shaming and
I just don't think the media has done a
sufficient job of investigating all
these accusations and allegations it
could do a great service by taking women
very seriously
what I would say today is I think there
are some cases where certainly they
could have done more but it was the
media of course who did expose the likes
of Harvey Weinstein and other serial
predances without that the metoo
movement would never have started so I
think you can argue this both ways I
think the the Counterpoint I would make
about Andrew and what he's done is that
the best way of course to test all the
allegations would have been in a
courtroom and he again
he was adamant I will go to court and
clear my name and we all believed him
and then at the last minute he caved and
gave someone he insisted he never I wish
millions of dollars I mean it made no
sense
I wish he had litigated the case I wish
he had uh had a jury trial I wish he had
taken it to a court but I don't know the
pressures that might have been put on
him uh to to settle but uh the
settlement itself does not include an
admission of guilt and that has to be
taken into account too but you know
settlements are negotiated people want
to end the lawsuit and there are
considerations on on all sides so
um the public has the right to judge the
totality the circumstances I agree with
you that exposing Predators is a very
important function of the of the media
but exposing people who make false
accusations is just as important you
know Blackstone the Great British
commentator belty better 10 guilty Go
free than one innocent be wrongly
confined the media has to look hard at
the possibility that there have been
some innocent people who have been char
charged and the media has failed largely
in its responsibility to dig deeply into
accusations that are somewhat
questionable okay well I've been talking
okay look I'll take a bit of a hit on
behalf of the meetings on some cases
that may be justified like criticism but
then I would return the fire and say
that like a lot of very high profile
powerful intelligent people you were one
of many who you know befriended Jeffrey
Epstein you acted for him in the
previous case of course
um and none of you seem to realize what
he was really like I mean I would say to
you Alan dershow it's just to return the
criticism if you with your legal brain
had done a little bit more digging
yourself then he may have been stopped a
lot earlier than he was because he was
clearly a Serial pedophile monster
but remember he met the queen uh he met
very prominent people he met presidents
of the United States Nobel Prize winners
I was never a personal uh friend or
acquaintance I was an academic a friend
nobody had any idea that he had done
anything wrong once he was charged I
became his lawyer and as a lawyer
obviously my job was to defend them and
try to get a deal and I did inquire very
deeply and I did find out ultimately uh
what happened but at that point I was
his lawyer and lawyers cannot disclose
uh confidence is that they learn in
legal representation but I did nothing
wrong at all I acted like any lawyer
would do when John Adams defended the
people who were accused of the Boston
Massacre he also found out what they had
done but he didn't quit the case the job
of a lawyer is to represent some of the
worst people I've also represented Ted
Kennedy and Bill Clinton and Natan
sharansky and half of my cases of
program Bono I've represented innocent
people on death row and I've saved their
lives so I've had a career that has been
filled with controversial people but I
don't turn in my clients and I certainly
don't do anything but zealously
represent him that's my job and I'm I'm
proud of that job I wish I had never met
Jeffrey Epstein because I wish I hadn't
had to go through eight years of being
falsely accused for something I didn't
do by somebody I never met but I was
prepared to go to trial and I was
prepared to litigate this thing uh to
the end and then of course the charges
were no that's true I think that she may
have made a mistake yeah listen I think
you were defamed and and Justice was
seen to service it it's cause but
eventually it took a long time in the
meantime you'll you would drive through
the mob which I think was extremely
unfortunate
um Alan good to talk to you thank you
very much indeed
likewise nice to talk to you as well
thank you let's get a reaction of this
especially I mean it this is a
complicated thing because at the heart
of it it's really we don't know right we
just don't know all we do know are the
facts is that Andrew befriended this
pedophile yes even after he was
convicted initially of pedophile
Behavior Andrew continued to see him
coming for four days in New York
infamously and we also know he vowed to
clear his name and then never did yeah I
mean my problem is
um not that he
befriended at scene when he didn't know
he was a pita Ball but after he was
released from present in full knowledge
of what he'd done he then goes to New
York to stay with them and it wasn't for
academic legal reasons
yeah he was on a jolly with his lots of
women
exactly and that is extremely
distasteful we also have the photograph
which
is not real one of the weirdest things
well not the best photograph well I mean
I I thought it looks like the man on
Sunday have nailed the fact that that
photograph may be real but what about
the bathtub
it's all the weirdest things I've ever
seen it takes it into it now we got it
again can we get it yeah it now reminds
me of the Duchess of our girls so these
are friends of the Maxwell's Elaine
Maxwell right who are pretending to be
Andrew and this girl who was his you
know the woman who's paid millions of
dollars to while saying he never met her
to prove that they couldn't have thrown
it in that bathtub this looks like proof
of the complete opposite Katie yeah yeah
it's an it's an extraordinary photograph
and and clearly doesn't do anything to
clear Andrew's name I mean I I think at
the end of the day he he said he was
going to go to court he'd be prepared to
do that be prepared to be investigated
by the FBI did none of that
um I think it sticks in the core for a
lot of people that the settlement was
deemed the easy way out I think Alan
made a good point though because he was
under huge pressure the queen wasn't
well she's coming towards the end of her
life the last thing that the royal
family would have needed was a big court
case like this they had enough with what
was going on with the court of the
sussexes across the pond but of course
Charles is now faced with all of this
and the eve of his
currently I mean the trouble is it's
always all about Andrew
um
you don't start even talking or thinking
about this sort of thing until after the
coronation right assuming he is innocent
then
if he was it's hypothetical what I'm
saying if he was it wouldn't really
matter whether he was trying to clear
his name or not because the point is
that Charles's plan for a streamlined
monarchy wasn't going to include Andrew
at the helm anyway he was going to be
demoted so this is just a distance
is a great chance for King Charles to
reset right the whole monarchy after 70
odd years of his mother's Reign his
glorious Reign this is the big moment
for him where he actually has a
coronation and his Queen consult
communicate yes I mean he must be
sitting with his head in his hands
wishing um he had a rather more amiable
relatives no I would be saying why on
Earth would he even countenance having
now Barry and Megan there with all their
cameras making notes repeating again
more private conversations
I think there will be a bigger route if
if he doesn't they're absence
because they wouldn't make one the best
answer to Harry and Megan is shut up go
away and nothing to do with anything is
you're missing the point the point of a
royal family is it has to be United not
United States
Charles should it be all one way why
should these two Renegade because
they're King shovel dirt all over their
families
peers
and this lasted me about all the loved
ones in the family
Victoria's family is supposed to
represent the idealized British family
and they've always been conscious of
that and it's something the taxpayer
conscious of to they do not like to see
a royal family divided Charles doesn't
have any choice William wants to punch
Harry's lights out I was told the other
day literally
very well but what happens what happens
if he sees him at the coronation decides
now's the moment I mean the eyes of a
throne punching his brother in the head
yeah
if one of your family had done this
right one of your siblings or child or
whatever if they'd done that what would
you do we're private individuals you
keep it in the private domain
unfortunately Harry hasn't done that I
think his father and his brother will
show that they can do better oh I think
that honestly they should cut him off
bang bang
you stay in Montecito you're not part of
this anymore you don't get the good
stuff you don't get the trinkets from
the institution that you've been
trashing and burying this poll in
America last week showing massively
reduced popularity you've got all the
Royals but the most unpopular now Harry
and Megan in America right because they
just don't know what they're doing
they're doing stupid and Charles is
riding top of those polls piers and I
think to extend that fight
they're on a mission to destroy the
monarchy and we in this country should
not accept it by the way it's not just
Charles's coronation it is the people's
colonies
we're paying for it but I think the
people appreciate Charles acting with
dignity a man who's risen the problem
says so the most dignified thing to do
is have the least dignified members of
his family not there that's what I call
preserving dignity the idea of Meghan
Markle and Harry after all they've done
sitting there beaming away in the front
row would make me puke well they won't
be in the front queue I mean just look
back to the Queen's service of
Thanksgiving during the Jubilee they can
be there in a position
exactly all right gotta leave it there
thank you ladies I appreciate it well
coming next tonight five black police
officers beat a black man to death in
Memphis in America time Nichols
was killed horrifically
but was he killed by racism and white
supremacy or by five black police
officers will debate that after the
break
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
well Tyree Nichols loved sunsets he was
a father he'd been able to photograph
The Twilight Sky and his home City of
Memphis with five black police officers
pulled him over the lady said it was for
reckless driving there's no evidence to
substantiate that it's still unclear why
they stopped him what is clear is that
Tyree Nichols was subjected to a Savage
and terrific beating taking sustained
blows from the officers as he cried out
for his mother and he died three days
later the beating was captured on body
Cam and CCTV in a warning viewers may
find this footage upsetting
what's up
well that is just what it looks like
it's five black officers beating a black
man horrific appalling incredibly hard
to watch not surprised by the global
revulsion to this brutality what I am
surprised by is the immediate attempts
by many high-profile liberal
commentators to blame this on racism and
white supremacy he is CNN commentator
van Jones
black people are at risk from police no
matter what color uh black white brown
you talk to African-Americans they'll
tell you
um it doesn't matter there's this
pervasive view from law enforcement that
if you're black or dangerous
really so black people killed a black
person
and that's racist well black lives
matter issued a statement saying that
all police represent the interests of
capitalism and impel State sanctioned
violence anyone who works within a
system of perpetuate State sanctioned
violence is complicit in upholding white
supremacy so these five black police
officers were white supremacists
apparently
Jamil Hill from the Atlantic agreed
explaining the entire system of policing
is based on white supremacist violence
again apparently nothing to do with just
five
horrible thugs wearing police uniforms
killing a black man it was apparently
about racism and white supremacy well
joining me now black lives matter
organizer and activist Iman Aiken and
rapper and podcaster zubi welcome to
both of you Iman I don't get this
narrative at all that is coming out it's
been coming here from people as well
that somehow this is all about racism
and white supremacy it's not it's about
five poorly trained thuggish black
police officers killing a black man who
did nothing to deserve it that's it
okay so I just have to start with saying
that video was absolutely disgusting one
of the worst videos I've ever seen right
it goes on and on yeah it was disgusting
there was two versions of it the body uh
the body footage and the of course the
pole from across the road absolutely
disgusting so I'm absolutely horrified
at the fact that of course it was five
black people
um but for me personally this is about
an abuse of power and a disregard of
human life and those individuals need to
be accountable for their actions that I
need to don't disagree what's it going
to do with racism or white supremacy so
people why are white people responsible
for this okay so people could also argue
that this is due to internalized racism
which is a byproduct of societal or
institutional racism also referred to as
white supremacy so black police officers
become white supremacist
racists who kill black people
because they work in an atmosphere of
white supremacy is that it
I can explain it a little bit better
okay so anti-blackness is baked into
society here and in the US and black
people are not impervious to that and so
what people fail to realize people are
anti-black Yep this exactly is let me
explain
so let me explain it let me explain it
peers so what people fail to realize is
that when black people have to contend
with racism they can end up
internalizing it and that can result in
low self-esteem self-loathing and
rejection of one's community and when
you combine those feelings which as we
know are also referred to as unconscious
bias when you have those feelings and
they are compounded by hierarchy and
power it can lead to an individual
abusing said power and projecting their
self-hate onto another and this is why
in my opinion why we see black and white
police officers killing more black
people than we do white reason why is
because of racism which includes
internalized racism Pierce right I think
that's complete nonsense don't be sure a
white man you don't understand exactly
I'm white therefore my skin color means
my skin color means I have nothing to do
all right well let me go to a black man
and see if he's allowed to have a view
what's your view
okay so I agree with the first half of
everything that was said there I agree
that the video was disgusting I agree
that this is an issue of training and I
agree that this is an issue of the human
heart I think that any attempt to put
the blame on this in any way shape or
form on racism or white supremacy or
white people in general is absolutely
ridiculous I also think it's pretty
degrading because this sort of idea
stems from the notion that black people
black men black women that we do not
have full agency and responsibility and
therefore accountability for our actions
and our words we end up in these
ridiculous situations where no matter
their permutation no matter what happens
even if there's not a single white
person involved in this situation in the
Memphis police force even the police the
police chief is a black woman the large
percentage of the force is black and
people are still trying to lean on this
white supremacy is the answer and the
reason for everything and honestly it's
lame and as someone who's lived my
entire life as a as a black male uh
certainly I've never been possessed by
this sort of Phantom of of white
supremacy that's made me want to attack
anybody let alone another black person
and I think that we need to put the
blame and responsibility squarely on the
individuals who were involved I
completely agree tragic that this young
man died I completely agree I mean just
to note some statistics about the
Memphis Police Department that 65
percent of Memphis are population is
black 58 of the entire police force in
Memphis is black the police chief was a
black woman right and so on and so on so
you take all that totality you think
working well where is this
institutionalized white supremacy coming
from given the institution is actually
served predominantly by black people for
a population that is predominantly black
as well so I don't get that point the
second point I mentioned this I think
there's a wider issue here
the demonization of the police in
America
calling them all a bunch of vile races
has led to many older experienced good
police officers who are not via racists
quitting the force all over the country
and as a result in Memphis for example
they had a massive reduction 20 between
2011 and 2017 of police officers 20 off
went from the force
and so to try and restore the numbers
they made it easier to become a police
officer they reduced the restrictions
reduced the qualifications
two of the five officers involved in
killing this poor young man went through
that process in that period of not being
required to have the same
sort of qualifications that they used to
to join the Memphis Police Department so
you have a a bunch of people being
brought in who are poorly trained who
are not qualified to do the job who end
up committing this kind of crime that
has nothing to do with racism and white
supremacy that has everything to do I
think with perhaps an over-demonized
force in general with a lot of bad
apples in it but over demonized Force
leading to many people quitting and
being replaced with people just not up
to the job I think it's well everything
that you said I don't disagree with and
I think it's not about conflating the
two things it's just about presenting a
different perspective an alternative
perspective that should be considered
because internal racism is a real thing
so therefore it should be you just heard
a black man yes very in a very
considered way say that basically you're
talking nonsense no so the idea I'll ask
that says do you believe they're
internal racism is nonsense do you
believe that black people cannot
internalize racism do you believe that
I don't believe that it's completely
impossible okay I don't think it's
impossible for that right I don't think
it's impossible for a person of any race
or ethnicity to Harbor hatred or
animosity towards people who may look
like them or share some things in common
what I don't what I completely disagree
with is the idea that in every single
one of these situations that no matter
what happens we just jump to white
supremacy as the problem you see we've
seen this happen many many times and I
agree with you I think one of the
biggest issues with it is okay I think
one of the biggest issues as well is
it's actually a distraction from a very
important conversation which appears was
leaning into there which is that when it
comes to the police in the USA and also
in other countries there's clearly an
issue of character qualifications
training I don't know exactly yeah and
Prejudice is the foundation for yes and
sexism misogyny racism and the list goes
on so if you have not dealt with it
again
none of which had anything to do with
this particular incident what are you
talking about just explain to you
internal racism which is based off of
president had nothing to do with why
these and I said it should be consistent
I said it should be considered well
let's maybe finish the point you're
making
okay the the okay even following on from
that point I'd also say this is mind
reading as well so even trying to bring
racism into this conversation let's say
these guys did not have guns and badges
let's say these were this was just a
group of random thugs five black men
beating up another black man even in
that situation even outside the police
force I've still seen situations where
people try to blame this somehow on this
Specter of white supremacy and as I've
said frankly it's embarrassing and
that's a black person I have just as
much agency and accountability okay
um as I said black people have full
responsibility and accountability just
like it would be ridiculous to see a
video of white people beating up a white
man there are videos out there of white
police beating up white people I would
also make the points
that if people genuinely believed it was
racism then given these scenes were as
horrific as the George Floyd killing in
my in my view no no better no worse I
mean this was went on for a much longer
period and was disgusting and abhorrent
to watch completely innocent guy just
getting beaten and then he died
um that given that if it was racism that
people genuinely believe was the
motivation we would see the same scenes
on the streets of cities All Over
America that we saw after George Floyd's
death we would see the riots we would
see burning cities we would see that
kind of intensity of reaction but the
truth is even the people claiming this
is about racism they don't believe it
because if they didn't believe that if
they did believe that they'd be out in
the streets saying it and they're not
saying it they are saying it because
they do believe it but they're not
protesting in the same way because in
their hearts they know it's not right I
agree with you in that I've always said
that I don't subscribe to any type of
hypocrisy right so if white people are
going to kill black people we should be
outraged if black people kill black
people who should be outraged so
therefore there are many things that
should be have said that I agree with
there are many things that you have said
that I agree of but what I'm also trying
to say is that firstly this is about
abuse of power and a disregard of Life
those individuals should have uh should
make sure that they're they're they are
accountable for them we can all agree on
that that is clear but we also need to
need to take into account that black
people internalize racism and they can
perpetuate that racism within
institutions that is the fact yeah I'll
tell you what is a fact this was five
black police officers killing a black
man not because of racism and white
supremacy or because anything a white
person but because they actually didn't
know how to do their jobs he got
completely out of control they behave
like a mob a frenzied mob just like and
they completely lost and they completely
lost control as well when white police
beat up you know what they're also thugs
as well because black people aren't just
thugs when they beat up black people I
didn't say black people can also be
perceived as sponsors
you can keep saying whatever you want
this had nothing to do with racism or
white supremacy and as zooby right I
actually think it's embarrassing didn't
you they were black thugs okay but you
don't call white people
can I say one more thing
I call White thugs white thugs there is
far more and first what I'm talking
about it's far more emphasis this is
this normality of media
final words of zoomi uh connotations
like [__] can I jump in here I I think
I I think that in all of our in in both
the US and in the UK when we can have
these conversations without the words
white and black even being brought into
the picture then I think it will be
making something that's a serious
conversation
I actually completely agree with that
I'm seriously pointed that you said that
I really talked about the police
brutality here in that context without
mentioning skin care you won't get
anything we would actually get somewhere
to trying to help the situation but by
making it about race where it doesn't
exist we actually cause more problems
appreciate you joining me thank you very
much good to have on the show
well coming next tonight Nicholas
sturgeon ties herself in knots again
about women she says a trans woman is a
woman it may not be a woman in a prison
context What on earth does that mean
well talk to Matt Walsh the maker of a
Smash Hit film what is a woman maybe he
can give us some advice about what a
woman is that's not
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back to double rapist to
Scotland named Adam Graham A Center
women's prison last week after
transitioning into a woman named Isla
Bryson beginning of his trial rapist has
now been moved and the Scottish
government's allegedly announced a pause
on the transfer of violent trans inmates
to women's prisons but Scottish first
Minister Nicholas sturgeon is still
struggling with this issue take a look
at this are all trans women women they
haven't answered that question well
that's not the point that we're dealing
with yeah trans women are women but in
the present context there is no
automatic right for a trans woman there
are context where a trans woman is not a
woman no there is
there is circumstances in which a trans
woman will be housed in the male prison
estate is there any context in which a
woman born as a woman will be housed in
the real estate look we're talking here
about trans women I'm now asking about
women born as women I don't think that
our circumstances there but it's
different for trans women yes and I'm
not so they're not equal that is not
that that is a risk assessment process
done for trans women
I mean it's complete and utter gibberish
and this is what happens when when the
woke mindset runs right this is where it
leads into complete and utter Insanity
that can't be explained even by the
people spewing it well during today's
pack talk to if you contribute to Esther
cracker and broadcaster Jenny Cleveland
I'm glad to be joined by daily wire
columnist and a man behind the Smash Hit
film what is a woman Matt Walsh Matt
Walsh uh I mean every time I think this
can't get more absurd this simple
question in terms of a response from
women we get something like that we're a
leader of a country Nicola sturgeon the
leader of Scotland simply incapable of
explaining why if trans women are women
then they have to be kept in male
prisons
yeah I mean if there weren't such frauds
and cowards you'd almost feel sorry for
them they backed themselves into this
corner and they're left they're left
with as you said absolute gibberish uh
because that's the that's the
fundamental incoherence at the bottom of
gender Theory it's totally incoherent
and all you have to do is ask some basic
questions and that's revealed and by the
way this idea of well we'll do a risk
assessment well look if it was a if
there are female prisoners uh even very
danger if there's an actual female
prisoner who was larger and stronger
um you'd have to do a risk assessment
there but there'd be no thought about
whether that prisoner goes to a woman's
prison or not right obviously that
prisoner's gonna be a women's prison
right so I mean I think you know in a
way this this case has really exposed
this whole issue actually in the most
sharpest possible way because even this
rapist ex-wife came out and said he
never mentioned any of his stuff when
they were married for eight years and
she thinks he's invented the whole
transitioning simply to get himself a
cushier a place in a women's prison
where course he would then be able to
prey on women which is what he's done
before which is why he's a convicted
rapist
and I say he because I just don't
believe that he's a genuine transitioner
at all I think he just scammed at
everybody including the legal system
yeah I think he is right and by the way
even if he was a quote genuine
transition right still call him here
because he means man that's what he is
no matter how he feels about himself I
do think it exposes something because at
the heart of this debate whether we're
talking about locker rooms or sports
teams or prisons it's always a question
of first of all what is a quote-unquote
trans woman how do you define it but
then also you have these competing
claims you have the you have the uh the
the the quote-unquote trans person who
says that well if you don't do as I say
it's going to make me feel bad about
myself then you have all the other
people who are affected who say well if
you let them do what they want then we
are going to be unsafe and when you when
you translate this over to a prison and
you're talking about putting violent
predators and sex offenders in with with
with women because if you don't the the
violent Predator will feel bad yeah it's
like okay well we can it's bad it's mad
as is the whole sporting thing well you
have six foot three inch swimmers
pulverizing women born to female bodies
in the pool and breaking all women's
records potentially irrevocably Jenny
can you defend any of this I mean I
think it's a really
Stark example of where this begins to
fall down because prisons are binary and
sex is binary gender is not binary
gender is a is a Continuum but but sex
is binary and whilst there is a kind of
drive to be inclusive and to be
welcoming it gets to a certain point
where when you're conflating gender and
sex when you have a situation where it's
either a male prison or a female prison
that's where this all throws out I'm not
going to try and defend you agree with
me blimey
returning the wokies in real time here
my my point about it is I think the way
you try and introduce you know Limitless
self-identity of any kind yeah this is
where it goes right it goes to insane
places which are actually dangerous this
is dangerous but it's also State
overreach and I feel like no one's
pointed this out because the the state
is not in the business of I'm sorry
accommodating the the needs of trans
identifying prisoners that's not their
business right you can feel how you want
like you said prisons are binary and
they're binary for a reason I went to a
gym this afternoon I was in the female
gym showers I can't imagine a person
born with a penis I.E a male being in
there it's horrifying so I I think even
the fact that you know people feel like
it's the government's business to
accommodate trans prison this is
completely proposed the thing that I
would like to know is I would like to
know where trans men go to prison
nobody's talking about that because
do we talk about trans men and men's
sports do we talk about different things
biologically the issue only works one
way thank you right biologically in a
swimming pool or sprinting or whatever
it may be people born to male bodies
have an advantage over female bodies
predominantly almost exclusively right
we separated the Sexes at the Olympics
and thing there's no Advantage with it I
mean they wouldn't exist men go to
prison and that would kind of really
shed light on all of his issues and well
you mentioned Jim's uh Esther when we
come back and talk to to Matt and then
you guys about this new extraordinary
viral digital craze of women shaming men
and looking at them in the gym
is this perverted conduct which should
lead to cancellation or is it just
people looking at each other in a
gymnasium more from Matt Walsh am I back
next
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
half of men fear being labeled creepy
for talking to women so-called digital
influencers like Jessica Fernandez might
be partly to blame
tens of millions of people watched a
video shot though from the gym which he
claimed a quote feral man was staring at
her Fernandez has since apologized for
thousands of similar videos are
circulated into huge audiences well back
with my pack and first of all Matt Walsh
I mean you've been following this Matt
it's a quite extraordinary Trend where
for most of the videos I've seen where
people are claiming this is appalling
Behavior it's just blokes in a gym
looking at people I mean but not in any
way that I would describe as predatory
or unpleasant
no of course not this is the trend as
women for whatever reason are recording
themselves the gym that's the first
problem is if you want to record
yourself working out maybe stay at your
home and do that but then it turns out
this is really a cover to basically
entrap men who might glance over in
their Direction by the way there's
there's a lot of reasons why somebody
might glance at you in the gym maybe one
reason is they find you physically
attractive God forbid it might also be
that I don't know your hogging equipment
maybe you there's equipment that you're
using while you're filming yourself and
muttering to yourself like a
schizophrenic and they want to use that
equipment so they're kind of lingering
around so they can use it those are all
kinds of reasons but this is this
ultimately is why men are paranoid in
just opening a conversation with a woman
obviously I get it the other way I've
started going back to the gym and I get
a lot of very hot women obviously almost
fainting on site naturally when they see
the big guns coming out but um is this a
serious I mean what is going on there
Jerry I think a lot of women feel that
they're being stared at the gym or
having their photo a lot of the footages
and aren't you going to gym to make
yourself look aesthetically more you're
going to the gym even if a man looking
at you you know like wow what
is
yeah well I I think a lot of women just
listen I've heard of many romances that
started at the gym I look the thing is I
think we're being too clinical about
this people meet in all sorts of
different settings again like Matt said
you could look at somebody when I'm
exercising that's you I'd very much like
to be complimented look at that asked
out that's great if anyone is listening
but you know the thing is they could
also be looking at they can also be
looking at you because your form is off
right they could be looking at you
because do you look at other people at
the gym yeah if you're hogging
about wars this is the thing when I go
to the gym I don't think you can avoid
looking at people because I'm looking up
to see what their forms like how they're
carrying certain weights are they
carrying more than me you know male or
female I don't really care I'm just I'm
quite curious about other people using a
gym am I now going to be something
appearing on Instagram influence
influences sites is some sort of perv
well it's possible and look by the way I
also I don't mean to be a victim blamer
here but but can we also say that if if
you're a woman and you don't want to you
don't want men to notice you in the gym
maybe wear more than your underwear to
go work out I mean these women in his
videos they're wearing sports bras and
like hot pants I mean how about put some
clothes on if you don't be able to look
at you this is victim blaming it off
Atwood here that uh men are afraid of
women laughing at them women are afraid
that men are going to kill them it is
not okay to say that it's a woman's
fault for wearing the wrong you think
the people looking over at people using
some equipment a gym are going to kill
them I think that taking photographs is
threatening staring at people is
photographing it are these Instagram
influencers they are videoing men taking
photographs of them and listening
um yes uh men please ask away uh Don't
Be Tamed by this boring attitude bad
words thank you back thank you whatever
you're up to Keep It Uncensored good
night
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]